thanks yaser we do have one of the
potential leaders going into the blitz
section most likely one of the
co-leaders going into uh the blitz
section Fabiano caruana with us Fabi uh
welcome back to the show tell us a bit
about today's rounds and how are you
feeling going into the blitz action yeah
there's a little bit of a shaky day
I I guess I could have lost my first two
games but I finished one and a half
points very fortunately
um first game was really tough I think
he sacrificed a piece I think he was
played brilliantly
um against kukash and you know then he
in the complications a long time he lost
control
but uh but I was really in danger then I
think Zion I was just dead lost
basically I kind of mixed up the
the line a little bit I'm not super
familiar with the line and it's
everything kind of looks the same in
this line so he knew the line better
than me uh he got a winning position but
it wasn't super easy and and I also
defended that one in the last game I
don't know
I feel like I played pretty dubiously in
the opening but uh then he sacrificed an
exchange completely unnecessarily and
then I I don't know if I could have
maybe played on but I saw no ideas and I
decided not to okay it was a good day
not to push myself just to interrupt you
for a second sorry I did win his game
against Richie report quite an important
result for him he was struggling in
today's rounds uh what is it about your
mentality because you had this type of
situations against ritual report and
against Google cash very similar in
which you can take the drop but you can
also play on in one it paid off in one
it didn't but still you were showing
very clear fighting Spirit how is your
mentality tell us a bit about that well
I thought against kukash like at the
moment when I could have taken a draw
and decided to play on I think it was
completely risk-free uh and against
Richie I was more or less winning and uh
so of course I'm not going to take a
draw then maybe I I
I kind of lost control I had to make
these like Split Second decisions of
should I maybe try to clean it up or
continue gambling and that didn't work
out but against Google cash I think it
was a completely sober decision
okay he has a Perpetual but that's the
best he has he he definitely can never
win this end here and and he still has
to prove it so I think that was just a
good decision but in general of course I
am trying to fight and take my chances
um but okay also try not to overextend
Too Much which is what I often have done
in the past we're trying to keep a bit
more control here Fabi uh
congratulations on a good rapid portion
we'll see you tomorrow in the Blitz